I was excited you can come on the show
because I've been watching girls show
not I didn't mean to be some creepy I've
been watching the show girls and that
doesn't work either I have been watching
this program you are in yeah and I
really enjoy it I think the writing is
fantastic I think the acting is terrific
I'm a big fan of the program and it
paints a kind of bleak at times picture
of what it's like for people in their
20s these days to be dating Yeah right
terrible and and yet it's getting a lot
of praise because people say it's
realistic and of course I wouldn't know
I'm in my late 70s and I feel great fear
I've had a lot of work done um and I'm
just curious is it that bad is dating
today if you're in your 20s is it that
bad uh it's a little worse worse than
how it's depicted on the show girls oh
no it's pretty bad yeah I'd say so
or just bad Marcus bad boys bad in
general it's all that foul language
these young people you Harry
it doesn't matter keep going it's fine I
know no silence I didn't mean that keep
going alright of course but it's but
it's bad I would say yeah I would say
it's kind of I mean in my experience I
haven't found it to be particularly
enjoyable
okay well describe like in some of the
dating situations that you're in what is
it that so it's so bad um what guys
you're not liking the caliber of guy
that you meet I would say most of all I
don't know I'm kind of a weirdo but like
90% of the time when I go on dates
I'm find myself thinking I could be
reading my book instead that's a bad
sign which i think is i hear is a bad
sign I don't know if you're looking into
someone's eyes at a romantic dinner and
their face fades out and a book fades in
yeah
that's a bad sign yeah it's pretty bad
sign um I don't know I've heard guys
just say pretty ridiculous things to me
like what like uh I think they're
pretentious it's not even that I think
like being a young actress and working
and trying to get work sort of makes it
difficult to date um and so I I don't
have a bunch of time anyway
and then I just find that it's like yeah
it's quite bleak like I had a guy once
tell me that he thought my ambition was
gonna break his heart he said that to
you yeah which I looked I was like this
has to be out of a movie but it wasn't
it was it was out of his mind brain
right where maybe he was just reading
the title of the book that you were
reading in front of him trying to make
conversation okay so give me another
example of something is just like a
bleak thing that a guy has said to you I
mean is it is it what
oh I'm just curious do guys do you think
they sometimes I wonder if people in
their 20s are the guy setting too high a
standard do you know what I mean are
they yeah you know what I mean yeah yeah
are they expecting too much or they you
know uh maybe I I mean oh it's that I
don't know um what do I know I'm only a
24 year old human um III was in the
doctor's office the other day and I ever
heard these two guys talking um and one
of them was talking together one and
they both looked like really concerned
they were like very deep in conversation
this one guy was like dude he's like she
answers the phone sometimes and she's
like can I call you back in a few
minutes and the other guy was like man
you got to end that now you this can't
be real I'm sure it is that's how I roll
man
so I mean so I don't know yeah I would
say if those are the standards the day
my wife says to me you got to call me
back and if I'm at I'm gone I'm just
gone that you're like in the room of
shellack Yeah right here
how we're our bicycle built for two yeah
if those are the standards then I'm
probably gonna have cats